hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we're talking about
robots we've talked about robots before
on mindscape it's a natural topic to
imagine but usually we're talking about
what kinds of robots there are what they
might be doing today we're gonna be
focusing on the human side what do human
beings do what should they do when they
interact with robots how should we think
about robots when we're dealing with
them
today's guest Kate darling is a
researcher at MIT Media Lab she's not an
engineer who builds robots she actually
comes from a social science background
she's interested in what people should
do with the fact that we tend to treat
robots as if they are human beings we
tend to anthropomorphize them we assign
tribute feelings and emotions and ideas
to robots even when we know that they
don't have them you don't need to be
looking like a human being as a robot to
get another human being to treat you
like a person we treat our Roombas like
people our laptops like people so what's
up with that what does it mean for the
future this is an area where as very
often when technology is advancing the
legal system and the philosophy and how
we think about these things lags behind
so anything we can do to get into our
brains what's going on ahead of time
will be very useful there's one other
thing a big announcement that I have and
want to share with you which is that it
looks like mindscape will be getting ads
getting advertisements at some point
we're not absolutely short I don't
exactly know what it's gonna happen but
that seems to be the direction in which
we're moving I don't know when it's
gonna happen so but I'll let you know
ahead of time I did go back and forth on
this I will be honest because obviously
ads are good because they get money and
I like money I will never you know try
to pretend otherwise on the other hand
you have to admit they kind of get in
the way of the actual substance of the
podcast I won't try to pretend that
either what pushed me over the edge into
the agreeing with the ad thing was the
idea that it would get a lot more
listeners it's not that I'm just taking
ads I'll be joining a network which will
publicize the podcast elsewhere bring it
to new audiences and that I really think
is important you know I
maybe I'm flattering myself but I enjoy
what we're doing here I think it's
interesting it's important I want to
share it with as many people as we can
and a big part of that is just getting
the word out and being part of a network
would be a huge benefit to that it won't
change the substance it won't change who
I get how long the podcast is what we
talk about any of those things it'll
just be a new platform on which the
podcast will appear so I'll keep you
updated on that
who knows robots maybe the robots will
be reading the ads maybe someday all
podcasts will just be invented by robots
and then consumed by robots maybe the
human beings will just break in the box
at the end of the day I don't know
that's what we're here to find out so
let's go
[Music]
Kate darling welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me Sean so
you're at the MIT Media Lab and you work
on robots so I think that for many of
the people in the audience they will
instantly assume that you spend your
time building robots or programming
robots or something like that but that's
not what you do in fact you come from a
legal background so tell us a little bit
how you got here and sort of what your
job is there in the robotic space yeah I
sadly don't build robots very bad at
that although I have tried I made a
little solar-powered robot that oh
that's more than me it moves it like
charges itself for that it moves a
little bit and that was that was my
great accomplishment in robotics but yes
it's correct I have a legal and Social
Sciences background and the way I got
here the short version is I love robots
and found a way to do something with
robots but the longer version is
probably that I have always been
interested in how systems shape human
behavior and so that's what originally
drew me to law and later to economics
and then to technology because all three
of those are systems that shape human
behavior sure and but you have a
wonderful story that I'm sure you've
told hundreds of times about the first
time that he started thinking about how
human beings react to robots yes yes I
was still a law student at that point
and I had bought a plio which is this
baby dinosaur robot that came out in
2007 this Japanese toy I bought it
because like I mentioned I I've always
loved robots this was a really cool one
it had all these motors and touch
sensors it responded to your touch it
was supposed to develop its own
personality depending on how you treated
it they had this infrared camera in the
snout and then one of the things that
had was a tilt sensor so it knew what
direction it was facing
uh-huh well it knew it was upside down
and it would respond to that
by mimicking distress and crying it was
it was a pretty realistic depiction of
being in pain and I thought that was
super cool and I would show it off to my
friends and be like hold it up by the
tail see what it does and one of my
friends held it up for a very long time
and it started to bother me so I I asked
him to put the robot back down and then
I started to pet it to make it stop
crying and that just kind of blew my
mind because I wasn't a very maternal
person but also I knew exactly how the
robot worked and I was compelled to be
kind to it anyway and so that really
sparked my curiosity about human robot
interaction and our psychology around
interacting with robots and I soon
discovered that it's not just me yeah
and and it's interesting because it's
teaching us I mean the surface level at
least it's not that insight doesn't
teach us anything about robots it
teaches us something about human beings
right and how we interface with the
world absolutely I think the most
fascinating thing to me about robotics
is what robots can teach us about human
psychology human behavior and
interacting with each other so what do
we know I mean is can we at this point
identify the features that your little
dinosaur had that made you connect with
it I mean there's a whole gamut of
different kinds of robots from Roombas
to self-driving cars I mean maybe even
we should count the little Tamagotchis
the little pets that have sold to kids
right and and we to different levels we
anthropomorphize these for some reason
or another oh yeah and it's not just
robots either we we have this inherent
tendency to anthropomorphize anything
you know the one of the first thing a
baby learns to recognize is a face
whether that's a real face or just an
image and this we have this deeply
ingrained tendency to project ourselves
and our own human-like qualities onto
other entities whether that's our pets
that we you know we
we see the dog looks guilty whether the
dog actually looks guilty you know we
don't really know or I recently read the
example that like people will see a
monkey yawning and the sea will be like
oh the monkeys forward when really is
just showing off the teeth that can rip
your face off so we we will often just
make all these assumptions about others
kids develop relationships to stuffed
animals we will you know we respond to
to a lot of different things one of the
things that we respond pretty strongly
to is movement we've kind of been
conditioned through evolution to be able
to recognize whether something is an
agent and moving or whether something is
an object because we've needed to detect
natural predators at least that's you
know the reason that the evolutionary
psychologists give us but it's
definitely true that studies show that
we're very quick to detect animal
movement and autonomous seeming movement
much more quickly than other types of
movement and the thing about robots is
that they move in exactly that type of
autonomous way so robots are physical
they exist in the physical world which
we kind of respond to as physical
creatures they move in this autonomous
way and then there are different design
elements that you can layer on top of
that to make people really really
respond to robust as though they were a
living thing so the you know the baby
dinosaur with the cute big eyes being
one example but you know people will
even have a response to the Roomba like
you mentioned do you have a member I do
not have a Roomba no do you have one do
are you attached to it I too have one we
did name it which a lot of people do and
I was just talking to the people from
iRobot that you know made the first the
Roomba the first you know real
successful robot vacuum cleaner and they
you know they say most people named
their room Bose
they'll send them in to get repaired and
they'll want the same one back they'll
be like Oh Meryl sweep is broken you
don't want a new one we want you to fix
Meryl sweep so people really people feel
bad for the room bo when it gets stuck
somewhere so even just
like a very simple robot that just moves
around your floor will cause people to
have this emotional response so it's
probably multifaceted right because I
think I don't know anything about
Tamagotchis but I do remember thinking
that you know hearing about the fad when
they came out and people would care for
their little virtual pets and they were
not embodied right they were just like
on a screen is have studies been done
about the different roles of being
anthropomorphic having a face moving all
these different aspects and how they
play into how we project organic nature
onto these robots well yeah there's
there are entire fields that research
this so the precursor to human robot
interaction is probably human-computer
interaction
which looked at you know the ways that
people are among other things the way
that people treat computers like social
entities and like we certainly blame
them when things go wrong let's put it
that way you blame them yeah but people
are so also polite to them there's this
really great study that you know cliff
bass and some other people did back to
the day where they showed that if you do
a task on a computer and then you're
asked to rate the computer's performance
and you're asked to rate it using a
different computer you'll be more honest
and more negative about how the computer
performed than if you're asked to do it
on the same computer because you have
this instinct that you don't want to
hurt the computers feelings
so people are we we're such suckers for
organizing anything you mentioned the
Tamagotchi there's also that video game
portal that'll is really in like 12 15
years ago I don't remember the in the
game you have this companion cube that
comes with you that's just this cube
that's just with you in every level and
then at the very end of the game I think
it's safe to spoil it
given how old the game is you're
supposed to incinerate the companion
cube to complete the last level and the
game designers were surprised to see
that a lot of people would sacrifice
themselves instead of burn up the cube
just because we do we do become attached
even to virtual things
but physicality is an additional layer
to that because there have been studies
that show that people will treat
something in their physical space with
even more empathy and even more like a
social actor than something on a screen
interesting and so I I will prod you to
give the other example that I've heard
you give it's not quite a study that you
did but you asked a bunch of people to
sort of bond with some robots and then
you ask them to do horrible things yes
this is with my friend Hannes gothel's
we we took the baby dinosaur robot that
I I now have four of at home we took
five of them we do this workshop at a
conference I think we had like 30 people
and we split them into five teams and
gave them each a robot and told them to
name the robot and play with it and have
them personify it a little like they've
built like hats out of pipe cleaners and
like did a little fashion contest and
then after like 45 minutes of them
bonding with this robot we unveiled a
hammer and a hatchet and we told them to
torture and kill them and it was it was
really it was so dramatic that we
actually had to start improvising
because we we had kind of expected there
would be a split in the room like some
people will be like oh sure I'll hit it
it's just a machine and some people
would be like no and we wanted to kind
of escalate the violence and see if that
split of people changed that was our
original plan but with this particular
group this was all adults between
probably 25 and 40 years of age and they
all absolutely refused to hit the robots
so we had to be like okay what are we
going to do okay
you can save your group's robot if you
hit this other groups robot with a
hammer and so they tried to do that and
even that they couldn't they just
couldn't do it so we we were finally
like okay everyone we're gonna destroy
all the robots unless someone takes a
hatchet to one of them and this guy
stood up and like took the hatchet and
the whole room kind of stood around and
we watched him like bring the hatchet
down on the robots neck and it was very
dramatic like people wince they like
turn their faces away we could see this
on the photos that we took on our phone
afterwards it was really interesting
other reasons like half serious half
joking moment of silence to the Fallen
robot and so like super dramatic
workshop you know very interesting not
science like you mentioned this was just
a workshop like there's so much going on
there but it did make me very curious
what would happen to look at some of the
factors in a more scientific setting so
it led to some research that I did later
on at the Media Lab with Kailash Nandi
and Cynthia Brazil where we were looking
at the correlation between people's
empathy and their willingness to hit a
robot okay good well I definitely get it
up at first this was at done at a
conference I mean did the people there
were robot people I guess or what kind
of people were there I was like one of
it was called lift it was one of those
like innovation conferences together you
know designers and technologists and all
sorts of people okay
and what part of me wants to say you
know that our immediate reaction we're
not in the room killing the robots we're
hearing about other people who are
reluctant to do it and our media
reaction is oh that's silly it's just a
robot right yeah because we're outside
the milieu but in some sense it's a
feature not a bug right like it's part
of who we are that our brains a tribute
you know meaningfulness and moral agency
even to objects that we know are
completely inanimate I'm glad you feel
that way I do you as well there are some
people who say this is a bad thing and
we need to discourage it we need to
educate people that they're dealing with
robots and to some extent I think that
you know there are some problems that
can arise for example people's behavior
might be able to be manipulated through
technology and we might design
technology in order to sell people
products or even worse and so that those
are some effects that I think we need to
be cautious about but generally I do not
think it is a bad thing when a child is
kind to a Roomba like I love that
people's first instinct is to be kind to
another entity
and I I think that's part of humanity
and I think that's something that we
should encourage and not discourage yeah
and empathy I had a podcast interview
with Paul bloom recently and it's
clearly been a very good podcast because
I keep referring it referring to it
in subsequent podcasts but he wrote he's
a Yale psychologist he wrote a book
called against empathy and his point is
that empathy is usually very unevenly
applied we have a lot of it's much
easier for us to be empathetic with
people like ourselves and that distorts
our view of the world were nicer to
people like ourselves and you know we're
kinder more just and so forth and so
instead of being empathetic he wants us
to just be rational about what it means
to be moral or immoral I pushed back on
that a little bit because I actually
think that empathy is very important to
being a rational and moral person in the
sense that it becomes too easy to ignore
people unlike ourselves when we don't
try to have empathy with them you know
sure it's easier to be empathetic with
people like ourselves but it's necessary
and important to try harder to be
empathetic with a wider range of people
I was not at the time thinking about
robots at all but you're saying that
there's some kind of relationship with
between how people interact with robots
and how they're more widely empathetic
is that true well that's that's
certainly what our very preliminary
research indicated we did look at the
correlation between people's tendencies
for empathy and how willing they were to
hit a robot and there seem to be you
know a connection there that you know
people who have very low empathic
concern for others that they are much
more likely to hit a very lifelike robot
and people who have high empathic
concern for others are more likely to
hesitate or even refuse I you know I
find Paul interesting because I both
agree and disagree with him kind of like
you like I you know I I think that yes
it's true that it can be problematic
that we only relate to people who are
like us or things that are like
it can be problematic that you know we
relate to robots because we see
ourselves in them and not you know to
certain other people that we don't see
ourselves in do you know we've
dehumanized entire swathes of other
people and of course we don't want to do
that in favor of things like robots that
you know don't inherently deserve our
empathy but there does seem to be
something to the emotional part of
empathy in that it kind of lights a fire
in you and makes you care at all like
you said I think that it's too easy if
you're a completely rational human to
just not even care and so I've noticed
myself since becoming a mother that I've
become so much more empathic generally
not just you know towards other mothers
because I've had this experience but
like for example in Boston in the winter
I was like walking around with the
stroller and people sometimes don't
shovel the sidewalks in front of their
houses and I was like why did what if
someone's in a wheelchair like I
suddenly realized how awful it must be
to be a disabled person in Boston and so
like I feel like by this emotion that I
have extends and makes me try and think
of other people as well in situations
where I might not have cared before um
yeah the flipside of both of those
things you know your example of having
become a mother and the fact that we
feel empathetic towards robots is that
it points it reminds us of how
involuntary a lot of who we are actually
is right like how much a lot of who we
are is a bunch of impulses that comes up
from beneath the surface not rational
careful cogitation about right and wrong
at a at a highly philosophically
sophisticated level oh absolutely and I
think it's it that that makes it
somewhat uncomfortable as someone an
uncomfortable realization but I think
it's very important to understand how
our relationships work why we empathize
with another entity how communication
works and that relationships can be very
one
sited you know we're learning so much
about ourselves by looking at how people
interact with robots and even computers
because we're starting to realize that
it's all about ourselves and all about
us projecting ourselves onto others and
you know we might learn more about our
human relationships human to human
relationships - as well I mean I mostly
want to talk about that side of things
but you did bring up you know you tossed
off the comment that we know that robots
don't actually deserve our empathy so
obviously I'm going to ask like do we
really know that is as robots become
more and more lifelike do we reach a
point where we start saying you know
they do deserve our empathy Shawn I you
know when I first got to MIT I was like
oh yeah
I haven't gonna be in the place where
they're developing the cutting-edge
robotic technology I'm so excited
and then like I got here and all the
robots are broken or they're falling
over and like which we're nowhere close
to developing a robot or an AI that can
feel anything um I do think that it's
worth considering whether we need to
treat robust a certain way because it
might have an impact on our own behavior
but I don't like I feel like the whole
robots deserve inherently rights because
they have consciousness like that's it
that's a fun conversation to have in a
bar over beer but it's not really I
don't I don't think we're gonna be there
anytime soon it's not practical yeah and
I and I agree and I think that you know
most of what you are thinking about
isn't even trying to get there right I
mean you're not trying to build the most
human conscious robot or even talking to
people who do you're interested in how
we deal with robots that are by complete
agreement very mechanical in their
insides right that there's no sense in
which they have feelings absolutely and
we you know they don't feel anything but
we feel for them and that's the
interesting thing and so what are the
applications here I mean
what good is a robot what kind is it
knowing that we care about robots there
there are a couple interesting
applications there have been some very
hopeful results in health and education
with using robots for example for quite
some time now researchers have been
looking at how to engage autistic
children with robots because they've
noticed that kids on the spectrum will
sometimes respond to robots in a way
that we haven't really seen before and
the the leading researchers in the field
say that this is probably because the
robot is it's very a very social thing
that they treat as a social actor but it
doesn't come with all the baggage that
an adult or another child would have
there's really yeah I am very
sympathetic some but I think robots yeah
but like but it's it's the interesting
thing is not only will they engage with
the robot they will engage more with
other people in the room as well if you
bring in a robot to play with them and
until now it's been kind of these
one-off studies in the lab that they've
done but they just recently last year
did a longer term study in people's
homes where they put robots in kids
homes that they interacted with for like
half an hour every day for a month and
this there's social skills when upward
like in a way that well you know just
you know on every measure that we care
about for these kids normally this would
take thousands and thousands of dollars
within the therapy to get those results
and they got it with with having them
interact with a robot now the catch was
that the skills decreased again when
they removed the robot at the end of the
study but that show is that there's so
much potential here another example I
like to make is sorry I just asking
heard that second what kind of robot was
it that they were interacting with um I
think they were using the the Jibo
platform Gebo was a consumer product for
a few years but recently shut their
doors but is still used as a research
platform so I think they were using a
Jibo was it did it something that looked
like a human being I look like a Pat
oh yeah the G I think the the closest
thing would be like the Pixar lamp so
it's so okay okay it has like a head
that swivels and looks at you and it has
like this is what animated dot in the
middle of the head that you know the
head kind of looks like a fried egg but
it's it's it's very cute it will move
around it really gives you the sense of
interacting with a social being
it's it's actually really cleverly
designed because when you try to make a
robot too human-like or too close to
something that people are intimately
familiar with it really disappoints
people's expectations because you know
they're expecting it to behave a certain
way whereas if you have this like Pixar
like animated thing people are much more
like to suspend their disbelief but also
it's interesting because one might have
guessed that they would want something
that was sort of tactile you know like
furry like a cat or a dog or something
like that but this is manifestly
technological it is um there are furry
ones which is the second example I was
going to talk about
I suspect they use geebo for the study
because like I mentioned robots are
broken around here and so it's very very
difficult to do a study in people's
homes where you can't go and fix the
robot and have that consistency that you
need for a long-term study and so they
needed to use a product that was stable
enough to do that with and I think G Bo
was was that's why they chose Cheetos
sure and so what was this other study so
the other um not necessarily a study but
the other robot that I think has a
really promising application is the Paro
baby seal robot have you seen that one
no it's so this one has been around for
quite some time they use it in nursing
homes and with dementia patients it's
really to see actually yeah yeah and
it's been like on TV shows it was on the
show master of none you know it's it's
it's gotten some fame but it's super
cute it makes these little movements it
gives you the sense of nurturing this
baby seal this was furry and soft to the
touch and it's it
turns out to be really important for
people who are in a situation where
they're just being taken care of by all
there is that's the whole life now to be
given the sense of nurturing something
that's psychologically really valuable
for them and I know it sounds super
creepy and people are like oh that's so
weird and gross that we're giving old
people robots instead of human care but
what it really is is a replacement for
animal therapy and it's been very
promising they've been able to use it
instead of medication to calm distressed
patients and so it's really hard to
argue that that's a bad thing
especially if you stop considering it a
human replacement and start looking at
it as animal therapy in a context where
we can't use real animals for a lot of
reasons yeah I mean I I can't imagine
people jacking this I don't get it why
would you object to this it's the
therapy is that is that sort of the dark
side of this fact that we're reacting on
the basis of our instincts not our
rationality I mean people have a
reaction that there's something in
trinsic ly off-putting or inhuman about
a robot compared to some other strategy
well I think people are just struggling
with this like in in kind of Western and
judeo-christian society we have this
really stark divide between things that
are alive and things that aren't alive
and so our rational brains are like oh
there's they're robots or machines
they're not alive and yet our
subconscious behavior towards robots is
very much treating them like living
things and I think that's just very
confusing to people and we haven't
really sorted that out in our culture
yet yeah for the autistic is is there
any more detailed explanation of what it
is that the word the benefit is coming
from well you know why is it that the
autistic kids are becoming more social
in the presence of this robot um I don't
know I'm not intimately familiar with
that I'm not sure that the researchers
actually know for example why the robots
worked so well with these kids but it's
certainly an opportunity to learn those
things by studying this and more depth
right I mean for the dementia patients
or for the elderly I you offered an
explanation which makes perfect sense to
me that
there's something that you get value
from not just being taken care of but
you're taking care of something right
you are nurturing that's something that
is valued I suspect having no expertise
here whatsoever that a lot of that we do
a disservice to a lot of elderly people
by removing all of their
responsibilities and authority right
like just by trying to take care of them
and put them in a very soft space where
they can't do anything or be hurt and
giving them a little bit more autonomy
would be better along many dimensions
yeah and and I guess people don't like
it because they say it's fake autonomy
like they're not actually nurturing
something and so they they don't think
it's authentic but I feel like you know
the way that we treat people now you
know stick them in front of a TV or we
medicate them or you know like you said
we we give them no autonomy I think that
this is so much better than what we're
currently doing and then they on the
other side there's the fact that like it
or not we're being surrounded by robots
right like forget about using them for
therapy whatever you know whether we're
working in factories or driving cars or
in our kitchen do we human beings have
to adapt to a new sort of way of dealing
with the world when someone so much of
the world is robotic and able to move
around well yeah of course I mean that's
also why I'm confused there are some
people who are like oh it's bad that we
treat robots like living things we need
to educate this out of people but I
think that's just gonna be the new
normal really because robots are moving
into shared spaces right now if they've
been behind factory walls and now
they're coming into all of these new
areas like you said into people's houses
into people's workplaces into
transportation systems hospitals the
military and I think we have to roll
with it and you know try to think about
you know whether they're any you know
harm's that could come from people's
interactions with robots whether we need
to you know think about consumer
protection issues for example but I
really think we need to be leaning into
the positive effects as well and within
the knowledge that you know this I know
this sounds like technological
determinism but you know it's
true these robots are coming it's coming
I'm with you there yeah I mean do you
know much more about robots than I do do
you know do you have a picture of what
it's going to be like 50 years from now
in terms of how robot I sized our daily
lives are gonna be fifty years from now
you can change the number but yeah like
if you go fifty years back like you can
think of all the changes oh my goodness
um well I I do think that we are gonna
see more more robots in households and
workplaces than we do right now like
right now we're at the very beginning of
people like having a Roomba having an
Alexa you know recently some companies
have closed their doors that we're
trying to create household robots that
do a little bit more than this
two things they tried and and failed but
I think that they're just slightly
before their time I think we will have
more and more robots in the household
they may not be Rosie from the Jetsons
they may be more single tasks robots but
that's definitely going to be a huge
shift I think we are entering an era of
human robot interaction right and it's
interesting to me that you know we treat
them I keep saying anthropomorphic but
that's not exactly right right because
we don't necessarily feed them like
people but like it's like animals right
whether or not they are explicitly made
to look animal-like so once we get not
like you say Rosie from the Jetsons but
just super Roombas it's gonna be
inevitable that we make them more and
more human in our minds I think well I'm
so glad you mentioned animals though
because I think one of the fallacies
that we still have is that we we
constantly compare robots to humans and
artificial intelligence to human
intelligence and you know whether that's
in stock photo images if you do a Google
search for AI you get all these human
brains or whether that's you know it's
talking about robots a job replacement I
think we're still very much thinking of
robots as like a recreating human
abilities in human tasks whereas it
so much better to think of them as an
animal equivalent I'm doing research on
a book on this right now that looks at
all the analogies between our history of
animal domestication and how our
integrating robotic technology now and
in the future because it's much it's a
much better analogy given that AI has
such a different skill set than we do
and we could be partnering with it
instead of trying to replace ourselves
right right and that reminds me of so
I'll say something controversial here
and we'll get comments I'm sure but
there's the issue of how we treat
animals just as there's the issue of how
we would treat robots right and you know
I have a lot of vegetarian followers I'm
not a vegetarian myself but I get that
this is an important issue and we should
think about it and I try to be
open-minded and listen to both sides but
one argument is you know if you had if
you raised a pig let's say from a little
piglet and it became your friend and
your pet then you wouldn't want to kill
it and eat it
and I actually I agree with that and I
don't think that it's a contradiction or
I don't think it's a moral failing I
think that it's just the fact that we
grow attached to things
animals robots people that we get to
know and the the problem with killing it
is not that there's some intrinsically
bad thing about killing it but it's that
our feelings are hurt when that happens
and I think that's a perfectly sensible
moral way to live Wow yeah that is
controversial I agree and disagree with
you all right so I think it's true that
if you look at the history of animal
rights and how we've treated animals
throughout history and today we are such
hypocrites and we we love to tell
ourselves that we care that animals have
consciousness or that they suffer but if
you look at throughout history which
animals we've protected and which
animals we don't really care about
we don't really decide according to
biological criteria I grew up in
Switzerland people eat horse
in Switzerland in the states that would
people would never eat horses we have
too much of an emotional connection to
horses but you know if you tell that to
European the European is like well
what's the difference between cows and
horses you know they're both delicious
why not eat them both so right so I'm
actually I'm trying to argue for both
sides I want to say the Europeans are
completely right what is the difference
between horses and cows but I want to
say look if as an American if the
culture you grew up in says that you are
you know turned off by the concept of
eating horses then don't eat them right
I think you know I completely agree that
we are hypocritical in practice you know
I'm not in favor of pain and suffering
and I think that we're terrible to
animals especially farm animals and so
forth and I'm all in favor of attempts
to be nicer to the animals that we do
raise for livestock but it's a that's a
different moral dilemma than whether or
not it's okay to eat them if they are
raised humanely I mean so you think that
just because we are hypocrites it's okay
no I think it's okay to heat them I
think that the the the thing that is not
okay is mistreatment right but you're
okay killing them yeah yeah so do you
make sure that the meat you eat is
humanely raised well you know I prefer
it but I'm also a realist about what
actions I can take you know will change
the world I would like laws that make it
not okay
to mistreat animals that's the like it's
the same thing with energy conservation
right like or water conservation I'm in
favor of social collective action to fix
these problems not me trying to be
individually virtuous that's a good
answer it's a good answer I have to say
though I have too much of Paul blooms
you know emotional empathy when it comes
to animals I've been a vegetarian since
January okay so yeah I can't I can't do
it you know I was breastfeeding and
realizing that animals you know nurse
there's many animals that we else nurse
their kids and I was just
like I can't can't eat them anymore I
well you know look it's a very emotional
issue and I think it's okay and it's in
flux I did see someone I was following
on Twitter I won't say who you know
tweeted something about how it's better
for the planet if you eat more plants
and less meat okay and there are so many
responses in the comments along the
lines of don't tell me how to live my
life I'm gonna have a big old steak and
you know just like comments that were
pictures of steak and they were like
like I eat steak this is not a thing but
people who eat meat are just as you know
sensitive and defensive snowflakes as
vegans or vegetarians are so I use any
moral high-ground anymore well I think
they're defensive because they know
there's no justification for eating meat
people don't the way that I know there's
no justification for my carbon footprint
and flying all over the place like I do
but you do right yeah yeah like I and I
do it too and I know it's bad I know
that me stopping doesn't change anything
really so again I'm in favor of you know
collective action to fix this problem
but anyway okay I think that you know
this is it's important because you know
it relates back to the robots because
you you know you said and I think it's
correct we're nowhere near making
artificially intelligent conscious
robots that we would have to afford the
same kinds of protections to that we
would people but in the living Kingdom
right in animals or plants there's a
continuum of consciousness and feelings
that we have to draw that line somewhere
and eventually that it's gonna become a
much harder question in the world of
robots I would think Shawn I have a
question yeah why do physicists always
want to talk about robot consciousness
it's always the physicists I don't think
so I mean I actually don't want to talk
about it but I mean it's a one extreme
right like one extreme is the Roomba
another extreme is artificial
intelligence and I just I'm just making
the point that there's a continuum
between them and we are changing so it's
actually I think a philosophers like to
talk about it more than physicists
because they will instantly leap to the
thought experiment whether or not it's
anywhere close to technologically
feasible yes it's true philosophers also
like this
it's true well you know as a
philosophical discussion I think it's
absolutely warranted and you know
relevant I just like I said I don't
think it's very practical to discuss if
we're looking at the you know near and
medium-term future or or as far as my
eye can see because we're not going to
like we're not gonna have machines that
approach the consciousness of you know
anything that we believe would warrant
right right yeah of a mouse we're not
going to come anywhere close to a mouse
right yeah and we don't give the mice
rights either yeah no exactly that's
right so perfectly fair and I so I do it
and I do think it's important because of
what the implications of your work and
what you're studying is much more about
how humans deal with robots
that we all agree are not conscious so
there's plenty to be learned there
you've been given the examples of
autistic children elderly dementia
patients but then we have to start
talking about the sex robots right you
know people using robots for perfectly
healthy grown-up people using robots for
other kinds of purposes let us say so do
you study that is that something you
learn about I don't study sex robots I
personally would have no problem with it
but it's uh it's very hard to do sex
research in America I don't know if
you've tried III don't have to do either
sex or drugs research but I've been told
by friends who do it's very very
difficult in both cases we're very
puritanical hey you can't raise money
for it you get ostracized by your
colleagues you know yeah I also the sex
robots you know it I think they also get
a disproportionate amount of attention I
mean like you said we have to talk about
sexuality Ruane wants to talk about the
sex robots I think there is some
interesting issues when it comes to sex
robots and it does tie into some of my
questions around does the use of
Technology influence human behavior but
there's also a lot of kind of
sensationalist headlines around this
sir baths yes we don't really have any
yet well that's right we have sex dolls
I guess right I mean the reason why I
thought of it was because this issue
that we don't need to sort of make the
robots look human in order to
anthropomorphize them I presume
therefore sex robots it's a it's a it
would be since they don't really exist
yet but it would be beneficial to make
them look human right or at least you
know some exaggerated version whatever
someone wants oh yes that's the sex
robot that you want because if you go
into a sex shop and you look the sex
toys made for women a lot of them don't
really look like you know there's like
there's still does that look like
dolphins like penises
we don't want it to look like man I
don't just say there's like a lot of
different form factors out there but I
think a joke said I mean you're right
that the sex dolls are the sex
quote-unquote robots that we are seeing
on the market do you resemble female
bodies and you know specific types of
female bodies which which is which also
raises some issues around
objectification of women and whether you
know Minoo I don't believe that sex
robots are any sort of replacement for
human sexual relationships but they
might be something that you know people
who don't have human sexual
relationships use because they're better
than nothing or they might be something
that supplement people's sexual
relationships so I'm not necessarily
concerned about humans being replaced
here but I am a little bit concerned
about kind of the the form factors and
we we just don't know whether people's
behavior towards sex robots is something
that is you know a healthy outlet for
example for sexual behavior that we
don't want performed among humans for
example pedophilia or whether it's
something that might you know perpetuate
and normalize that behavior and makes
them want more of it we we don't know
and like I said it's pretty impossible
to research well yeah I guess that's
what I was gonna say so
you're right we don't know it you could
easily imagine it going either way right
that having this kind of robot either is
an outlet and therefore keeps real
people safe from harm or it encourages
it and this is an empirical question you
should study it but but you're saying
that it's just hard as a practical
matter to actually study things like
that it is I mean in other countries
like Germany and Canada they are doing
some research on pedophilia which you it
like absolutely cannot even do in the
United States for a lot of reasons
including legal reasons but you know as
an empirical question it's also a very
difficult one to get at it it's like the
violence in video game debate it's like
the pornography debate we have some
research that tries to get at those
questions but it's not very conclusive
it's it's very difficult to do these
studies but I do think that robots
warrant reconsideration of these issues
because of their physicality I think
that that's it it's so much more
immersive and visceral to engage with a
robot than with something on a screen
and violence is another example which is
probably analogous to sex in some sense
we could imagine that certain people
have violent tendencies and maybe that
could be ameliorated if they could take
it out on robots right or it would just
encourage them and you know it's very
analogous to the video game debate also
but is that something where we're able
to do research a little bit easier than
the sex question I mean the research is
well anything is easier to do research
on pen sex in America but it that that
is it is a very difficult question so
you know some of some of the research
that's been done on human robot
interaction is starting to look at
connections between people's tendencies
for empathy and how they treat robots
like mine my research but also other
people are looking at this but the
question of does interacting with robots
change people's empathise is a more
difficult one that you know we would
like to get at and I'd like to think of
ways to get at it but it's it's going to
take a while and that's unfortunate
because we kind of need to know sooner
rather than later as robotic design gets
more and more lifelike you know well we
want to know whether we need to be
policing people's behavior or having age
restrictions on certain robots or even
having legal you know protections for
certain robots that restrict what people
can and can't do with them in order to
prevent people from becoming
desensitized to certain behaviors yeah
yeah so that do you do you collaborate
with psychologists sociologists do that
are they studying these questions of how
people's behavior can be changed by
dealing with robots in different ways
you know some people have reached out to
me I've stopped doing experimental
research I I haven't done any for a few
years because I'm writing a book right
now but when I get back into it I'm
planning on getting in touch with people
because yeah of course this is very
interdisciplinary work you need people
who understand the technology people
understand the psychology it's and and
that that's another difficulty in
academia
even though nowadays we we claim that
you know interdisciplinarity is
important the institutional structures
don't always support it that well and
I'm fortunate yeah well yeah you know
the Media Lab is pretty good at it so
I'm hoping that I can do some
interdisciplinary work on this and
collaborate with a few other people
later on yeah it does see I mean you
mentioned like it's happening right like
it or not and as slow as academia is the
legal system is a whole other thing
right I did have a podcast with uLTA
Chara who is a bioethicists and law
professor and you know biology is a area
where things are changing very rapidly
with gene editing and designer babies
and so forth and the law is always slow
to catch up do you think that how how
good a shape is the law end when it
comes to our future robot interactions
oh terrible it's terrible and sometimes
it's good that the laws so far behind
like we would not have the
as we know it if you know the
legislators had had gotten their hands
on it early at the same time now we're
dealing with you know some consumer
protection issues and privacy issues and
other issues because the law is still
behind even though we've had the
internet for a while so it's um it's a
constant struggle especially as the pace
of Technology really picks up and
biology is a great example I mean wow I
yeah we need people who understand
policy and law and understand technology
and biology and and the cutting edge of
innovation to be working together on
this
that doesn't happen nearly enough I'm
part of this community of people who are
trying to bring policymakers and
roboticists and people who work in in
those fields together with you know some
limited but some success we we have this
conference that's happening every year
there's about to be a policy workshop in
DC with a bunch of policy makers but
yeah it's it's a constant struggle the
the law is usually based on you know
superstition or lobbying and yeah and
not based on it it's also reactive right
like some terrible thing happens and
then we pass a law against it if it's a
new kind of terrible thing oh yeah and
and we need more evidence-based policy
but for that we also need to have the
data to have the evidence that we can
point to and in human robot interaction
there are still some open questions that
haven't been explored I mean what so
both what are those open questions and
what are the the biggest legal issues in
your mind like what what do you wish
legislators or at least congressional
staffers we're worrying about well okay
so do you mean like in my personal focus
and work or do you mean generally in
robotics whichever you want to do first
well so my personal focus is really on
the ways that people treat robots like
they're alive even though they know that
they're just machines and so the thing
that I really want policymakers to be
aware of is our in particular consumer
protection agencies is the fact that
if you take the persuasive design that
we've developed on the internet you know
getting people to click on buttons
because their specific color using all
these tricks from like casinos to get
people to interact with their devices
more if you take that and apply it to a
social robot it's just putting it on
steroids because you know a social robot
is gonna be so persuasive and so
engaging to people and that Plus
capitalism is you know a recipe for some
consumer protection issues that I think
we will need to figure out sooner rather
than later so I that's that's what I
think but you know beyond that there
there are many many issues in robotics
that that really warrant legal
consideration from autonomous weapon
systems to responsibility for harm to
you know automation and and the work
force
I mean there's so many or oh my gosh
algorithmic bias is a huge one that
fortunately has gotten a lot of
attention attention recently and there
are a lot of great people working on
that but yeah there's there's a lot
going on actually maybe not every
listener is very familiar with that what
is the issue with algorithmic bias so we
like to think of artificial intelligence
as being more neutral in its decision
making than a person and so if you're a
company and you want to remove bias from
your hiring process for example you
might think it's a good idea to take an
algorithm to train it on you know what
people have been successful in your
company in the past and have it pick
applicants instead of having you know a
human pick the applicants who might be
swayed by like certain names or who
knows what so companies have actually
done this Amazon did this recently and
got in trouble for it because it turns
out if you train an algorithm on
historical data which is what we do with
all the algorithms it will incorporate a
lot of biases like for example the fact
that Union used to hire a lot of women
in your company and so now the algorithm
is gonna be like oh well women haven't
been
successful this company so we're gonna
weed all those out so so that's just a
very simple example but we we are seeing
these systems being deployed in areas
like criminal justice making decisions
over whether people get out on bail or
not making you know making decisions
over you know whether people get hired
or fired entire rating systems for
people's professions have been automated
in this way and it's it's heartbreaking
because not only is the data usually
biased but we usually don't have any
insight into how these decisions were
made a lot of these systems are
developed by you know companies it gets
contracted out it's in a black box it's
protected by an electric property or or
even you know the the algorithm is so
complex that you humans can't understand
how it came up with the decision we just
trust that it was a good one but I'm
sure there's that you know there's a lot
of problems with this obviously and data
scientists fortunately are turning some
of their attention towards this so
basically that mean it's a garbage in
garbage out problem right if you train a
computer on your bias ease it will end
up reflecting your biases oh yeah of
course I mean that's the problem with
technology in general like people oh my
gosh Lee has someone here at the lab
joyful and weeny she does fantastic work
she's a woman of color and she was
working on this she was she's
programming something I required facial
recognition and she realized that the
system couldn't recognize her face
because her skin is black to Italy so
she had to she had to wear a white mask
so that the system would see her and
we've seen this over and over again like
photography automatic like faucets in
the bathroom facial recognition
technology is built by largely you know
young affluent white men who don't think
too you know incorporate different types
of skin color that's just one example
and it's not their fault
everyone has blind spots based on their
life experience but we need more
diversity in the teams that are building
technology we need to be a way
of the biases and the data that we're
training these systems with and
currently I think we're a little bit -
we we trust technology a little bit too
much to be neutral yeah and and that
goes back to something you mentioned in
passing I want to come back to about
responsibility and where we put it you
know we we have increasing you know
things are being done in our world
increasingly by automated systems by
robots by computer programs and
sometimes things will go wrong sometimes
it's inevitable sometimes it could have
been avoided
and but we have a system when human
beings do something and it goes wrong
for blaming them and holding them
accountable and holding them responsible
and what do we do when the thing that
went wrong is an automated system rather
than a biological one well it seems like
an unsolvable problem we do have some
things that we can draw on throughout
history - to look at this now of course
this isn't going to help in cases where
we have a black box problem which is why
you know the EU for example is looking
at trying to have transparency in
algorithmic decision-making so that you
can at least see what happened and the
decision-making process but when it
comes to just these autonomous entities
making a decision and causing harm we
can look at animals we do have a history
of assigning responsibility when animals
have caused harm in the past I think of
this you know in particular when we
think about robots and automated weapon
systems and things where robots are
causing physical harm we've dealt with
this issue throughout history ever since
the first laws known to humankind you
know what happens if my ox wanders off
and Gore's someone in the street who's
responsible for that and we have
different solutions to that like it's
not like we found the one golden
solution it depends a little bit on
culture and and other things but we can
look at that history and try and draw
from it a little bit I was just recently
talking to someone at a conference who
was involved in some these a roboticist
works on autonomous vehicles and he was
talking to some lawmakers in England
about how to regulate autonomous
vehicles and they were like oh oh
well you know we have this law of the
horse from like the 17th century that
leg perfectly applies here and so they
started drawing on that so you know it's
not as new a problem as people think
right okay yeah actually that does make
sense and again it fits in with the we
can learn something about how to deal
with robots by studying how we deal with
animals
more broadly right I mean I personally
love that analogy if did yes doesn't
hold for everything of course but well I
wanted to I mean before before I forget
we you know you mentioned the usefulness
of these robots to autistic children or
elderly people with dementia
I wonder think about the usefulness of
robots in a similar way today
intentionally anthropomorphize robots to
you know grown-up regular people or you
know the majority of people who we think
about will will we be having increasing
robot nannies or robot schoolteachers
anytime soon robot nurses well whether
we will or not is a different question
from whether or not we should yes I
personally think it's so boring to just
try and you know create robots that do
something that a human can do that's
just like I understand that sometimes
there's a need for that like for example
for some for a dangerous job that you
know we don't want people putting
themselves in danger for yeah we might
want a robot to automate that but the
robot nannies or like people taking on a
function that like relies a lot on human
social factors I think that's I think
that would be better done by humans
honestly if it's not where robots have
the comparative advantage right no
absolutely not and and you know people
argue oh well you know there are certain
countries where we have over aging
populations and you know we need robots
to take because we don't have enough
people to do you know caretaking jobs
for example but you know sometimes the
problem there is very strict immigration
policies and general you know issues in
society that maybe aren't best solved by
throwing robots of the problem like
maybe we need to have a broader
conversation about what it means for
example for blue-collar
workers who've lost their job to not
want to become a nurse because it's too
feminine in their minds you know we we
have a lot of jobs and caretaking in the
u.s. that you know where people are
needed and at the same time we have
people complaining that all the jobs are
getting lost and it's you know there's a
lot of culture and identity and other
conversations tied up in that that we
might want to be having rather than
turning to technology technological
solution ISM I guess yeah okay mean it's
a good point because I think that one of
the first things to people I think we've
touched on this already first things
people think of when they imagine the
robotic future is robots that are
exactly like humans right that are
conscious and look like human beings and
even if we put that aside and say well
the robots don't need to be like humans
they can be different and have different
things you're saying that we still you
know look at the functions filled by
human beings and say what if we filled
them with robots and we might want to
say well what if they're just it
completely different functions the
robots are much better at and we should
be looking at those yeah I think it's so
much there's so much more potential in
thinking outside of the box here and
thinking about okay what are robots good
at and how can we use that to make us
more productive or have us do our jobs
better I think that there's way more
potential in thinking like that than in
thinking of how do we recreate human
ability yeah right now in Pasadena right
near Caltech where I work there is I
don't know if it's the world's first but
there is a burger joint that has a
robotic burger flipper right what's the
what's the spatula over the burger flips
it you can watch it right there they
sell it as a as a tourist attraction and
and I was never quite sure why that was
an improvement over anything but I mean
there's some novelty effect there again
there's there's some novelty effect but
so okay to close then I'll just give you
an opportunity to prognosticate a little
bit like what what or maybe if not
you're directly predicting the future
give us a little bit of a hint for those
of us who are not following the latest
robot news what we should keep in mind
or keep an eye out for
the robotic future not just building
robots but you know the legal and moral
and personal issues that you care about
well I think one of the things that
people really have trouble wrapping
their minds around but as people have
more robots in their lives are getting
more comfortable with is this idea that
we do treat robots sort of like living
things even though we know that they're
just machines and so having that
awareness I think it helps you not be a
surprised by it and helps lessen the
confusion that we're seeing in in our
society at least but another thing that
I really want to point out is that the
way that artificial intelligence
currently is being built and learns is
by collecting massive amounts of data
and feeding it to the machines and you
know we now have the processing power to
to be able to do something with that
data and like there's some really cool
things but a lot of data collection I
think is could be problematic for
people's privacy interests and that's
something that people don't think about
a lot and even I see it in myself like
we have an Alexa at home it's so
practical to be able to order diapers
hands-free you know you have a toddler
and so we're you know we don't mind
having a microphone in our home that's
listening to everything because we've
traded our privacy for that
functionality and so we don't have an
incentive to curb that the companies
don't have an incentive to curb that so
we need legislation to have our backs
because you know I I think privacy is
it's really important you know maybe not
for me but for the poor families who get
targeted with advertisements trying to
sell them you know scammy loans or
education programs you know there are so
many examples of how people get
exploited by all this data collection
and I think we need to be aware of that
yeah I kind of have a fatalistic
attitude towards this I suspect that
privacy is going to go away you know I
don't think it should I think we should
try to protect it but people don't seem
that interested in trying to protect it
versus
the pressure to give it up and the
possible benefits they can get from
giving it up but like we have to fight
child like we do we do it doesn't impact
you maybe as like a very privileged
white man but it impacts so many people
who are you know less fortunate and and
they're just I just we have to fight
this I and I don't believe that privacy
is dead
I believe that privacy is an entire
spectrum and that if we just let this
unbridled capitalism roll over us
they're gonna find newer and newer ways
to just exploit people and so we need to
at least try to slow it down a little
all right I will take that as a good
optimistic message that we should you
know even even if it's a pessimistic
message in the sense that there's this
huge problem facing us it's an
optimistic one that we can fight and do
something about it I think so all right
Kate darling thanks so much for being on
the podcast thanks Sean
[Music]
you
[Music]